Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
HI, AGAIN, SHARKS.
[ Singsong voice ]
HE'S BA-ACK.
YOU'RE AMAZING.
I'M VERY IMPRESSED.
THE POWER OF "SHARK TANK."
I THINK
IT'S THE POWER OF YOU.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
Herjavec:
YOU'RE THE REAL DEAL.
YOU ARE PROBABLY
THE BEST ENTREPRENEUR
WE'VE EVER HAD HERE.
YOU UNDERSTAND THE OFFERS?
$20 MILLION VALUATION.
$13 MILLION.
Narrator: ...AND FIGHT EACH
OTHER FOR A DEAL.
YOU SAID IT WASN'T
ABOUT THE MONEY.
THEY KEEP ON RESPONDING
BASED OFF THE MONEY.
OH, THAT'S CRAP.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
ONE MOMENT IT WAS THERE,
AND THEN POOF, YOU LOSE A DEAL.
NO, I'M SERIOUS.
I'M SERIOUS, TOO.
NO. NOT HAPPENING.
OH, MY GOD.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
MY NAME IS DAVE ALWAN,
AND I'M FROM PEORIA, ILLINOIS.
MY COMPANY IS ECHO VALLEY MEATS,
AND WE SPECIALIZE IN THE BEST
MEAT PRODUCTS IN THE WORLD.
THANK YOU.
HAVE A GREAT DAY.
I ACTUALLY PITCHED MY BUSINESS
ON "SHARK TANK"
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO
AND WALKED AWAY WITHOUT A DEAL.
I CAN'T CALL YOUR BUSINESS PLAN
BAD BECAUSE THERE ISN'T ONE.
YOU MAKE A GREAT PRODUCT, BUT
YOU'RE COMING IN UNPREPARED.
THAT DOESN'T CUT IT.
I'M OUT.
Alwan: I KEPT MY CHIN HIGH, BUT
INSIDE, IT WAS GUT-WRENCHING.
I TRULY DIDN'T HAVE
A GOOD ENOUGH BUSINESS PLAN.
I KNEW I HAD TO GO BACK
AND DIG DEEP INTO MY COMPANY,
FIGURE OUT ALL MY COSTS, AND
COME UP WITH A BUSINESS PLAN,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I DID.
SO, WE FINALLY GOT THIS REPORT
BACK FROM THE UNIVERSITY,
AND NOW WE KNOW WHAT IT ENTAILS
TO ACQUIRE A NEW CUSTOMER.
NOW THAT I HAVE
THE MARKETING SIDE DOWN
AND MY CUSTOMER-ACQUISITION
COSTS DOWN, I KNOW MY NUMBERS.
I AM EXCITED.
I'M COMING BACK IN THE TANK
BECAUSE I WANT A DEAL.
MORE IMPORTANTLY,
I WANT A SHARK AS A PARTNER.
THE SHARKS MIGHT HAVE GOT
THE BEST OF ME
THE FIRST TIME AROUND,
BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU, THIS TIME,
I'M GONNA BLOW THEM
OUT OF THE WATER.
HI, AGAIN, SHARKS.
I'M DAVE ALWAN OF ECHO VALLEY
MEATS FROM PEORIA, ILLINOIS.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER ME
FROM SEASON 4
AND MY DELICIOUS MEAT PRODUCTS.
[ Singsong voice ]
HE'S BA-ACK.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I DIDN'T GET A DEAL,
AND I WAS DEVASTATED,
BUT I WALKED OUT THOSE DOORS,
HELD MY HEAD HIGH.
YOUR TOUGH QUESTIONS
MADE ME GO HOME
AND SCRUTINIZE MY BUSINESS AND
BECOME A BETTER ENTREPRENEUR.
LAST TIME I WAS HERE,
I WAS ASKING FOR $300,000
FOR 20% EQUITY.
NOW I AM CUTTING IT IN HALF --
$150,000 FOR THE SAME 20% EQUITY
IN MY BUSINESS.
I AM HERE TO MAKE A DEAL.
MY COMPANY, ECHO VALLEY MEATS,
SPECIALIZES
IN THAT OLD-FASHIONED
BUTCHER-SHOP QUALITY,
AND WE DELIVER THE MOST
DELICIOUS MEATS AND TREATS
THROUGH OUR WEBSITE
AND GIFT CATALOG,
AND I KNOW THE MEAT
BUSINESS BETTER THAN ANYONE.
I CAN'T COME EMPTY-HANDED.
ALL RIGHT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
Alwan:
I BROUGHT MY SON, JORDAN.
IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY,
THIS FOOD WAS DELICIOUS.
YEAH.
YEAH?
IT WAS AMAZING.
I REMEMBER IT.
Cuban:
WE ORDER IT THANKSGIVING.
WE ORDER IT EVERY CHRISTMAS.
I EAT THOSE CHEESE
GARLIC SPREAD THINGS
AND GAIN ABOUT 15 POUNDS.
I HATE THOSE. DON'T BRING
THEM ANYWHERE NEAR ME.
Alwan: HAND THEM OUT.
Greiner: [ CHUCKLES ]
OH, THIS LOOKS GOOD.
LADIES FIRST, PLEASE.
OH, THANK YOU.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
Herjavec:
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TO DIE FOR.
MR. O'LEARY.
THANK YOU, JORDAN.
THAT'S GREAT.
FOR YOU.
I'M JUST GONNA START EATING,
DAVE. I'M NOT EVEN WAITING
TILL THEY GET THEIRS.
PLEASE EAT.
EVERYTHING ON THERE
IS MY OWN RECIPE.
THESE ARE SO GOOD.
John: FANTASTIC.
SEE YOU, JORDAN.
LATER, JORDAN.
BYE, JORDAN.
COME BACK WITH MORE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WHAT HAPPENED TO SALES
AFTER YOU WERE ON THE SHOW?
SALES, AFTER THE SHOW,
EXPLODED.
BUSINESS HAS NEVER BEEN BETTER,
BUT I TOOK YOUR ADVICE
AND REALIZED THE ONE OPPORTUNITY
I HAVE TO SCALE
IS THE MAIL-ORDER INDUSTRY.
IT'S NOT MY RETAIL,
AND IT'S NOT MY CATERING.
WE DECIDED TO SPLIT
THE MAIL-ORDER OFF
INTO ITS OWN ENTITY NOW.
PRE-"SHARK TANK," LAST YEAR,
WAS ROUGHLY $190,000.
RIGHT NOW, WE'VE BROKE
$1.4 MILLION IN OUR MAIL ORDER.
Greiner: REALLY? WOW.
OH!
JUST THE MAIL-ORDER.
JUST THE MAIL-ORDER ALONE.
ARE YOU SELLING US TODAY
JUST THE MAIL-ORDER?
JUST THE MAIL-ORDER,
WHICH I FEEL HAS
THE MOST POTENTIAL TO SCALE.
AH. THAT'S WHY YOU'RE ASKING
FOR LESS MONEY.
AS I RECALL, LAST TIME
YOU WERE HERE, DAVE,
WHERE YOU RAN INTO PROBLEMS
WASN'T NECESSARILY
JUST VALUATION.
YOU DIDN'T KNOW
YOUR CUSTOMER ACQUISITION COSTS.
KEVIN, THAT NUMBER IS $12,
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY,
IT ONLY COSTS $1
TO RETAIN THAT CUSTOMER.
WE'VE HAD GREAT RETENTION --
BETWEEN 35% AND 40% HAVE CAME
BACK AND ORDERED MULTIPLE TIMES,
JUST LIKE MR. CUBAN.
Greiner: REALLY?
YES.
SO IN THE $1.4 MILLION,
WHAT WAS YOUR PROFIT OF THAT?
UH, APPROXIMATELY
$260,000. 18.3%.
IN THIS CALENDAR YEAR,
HOW MUCH CASH
WILL THE MAIL-ORDER DIVISION
THAT YOU'RE SELLING
THIS EQUITY IN GENERATE?
WE ARE PROJECTING
ABOUT $1.8 MILLION
WITH A NET OF APPROXIMATELY
$400,000.
THIS IS A GREAT STORY.
YEP. DAVE, HOW MUCH HAS
THE RETAIL BUSINESS,
THE OTHER BUSINESS,
GROWN?
12%, 15%.
IT DOES NOT NET QUITE AS MUCH
AS THE MAIL-ORDER BUSINESS.
RETAIL IS ABOUT 10% TO 12%.
MAIL-ORDER'S 18.3%.
MAN, YOU HAVE YOUR NUMBERS DOWN
THIS TIME.
SO, LAST TIME YOU WERE HERE, ONE
OF MY ISSUES WAS COMPETITION,
FIGHTING THE BIG GUYS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
O'Leary: LET'S TAKE OMAHA.
THEY DISCOUNT AGGRESSIVELY
JUST BEFORE THANKSGIVING.
THEY DO IT AGAIN
TOWARDS THE HOLIDAYS.
I MEAN, THEY MAKE
REALLY BIG OFFERS.
SURE.
AND THEY'RE ACQUIRING
CUSTOMERS THAT WAY.
IT'S VERY COMPELLING.
Alwan: AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M GONNA DO WITH THE MONEY.
IT GIVES ME A LITTLE BIT BETTER
BUYING POWER.
PRIME RIBS AND HAMS
DIP AFTER EASTER
BECAUSE NOBODY'S GONNA BUY
THOSE AGAIN UNTIL CHRISTMAS,
SO WHEN THE MARKET SOFTENS,
I CAN THEN TAKE THAT CASH
AND GET ALL OF MY INVENTORY
BOUGHT IN
AT A LOWER TIME OF THE YEAR
BECAUSE I KNOW THE MARKET
SO WELL.
I'M JUST CURIOUS. HOW LONG
CAN YOU BUY INVENTORY AHEAD?
THE USDA SAYS
THEY DON'T REALLY LIKE ANYTHING
LONGER THAN A YEAR.
SIX TO EIGHT MONTHS IS
REALLY MY RULE OF THUMB.
Herjavec: IF YOU BUY IT ON THE
10th MONTH VERSUS THE 6th MONTH,
DOES THE QUALITY CHANGE?
NO, BECAUSE IT'S VACUUM-PACKED
INTO OUR FREEZER.
YOU'RE AMAZING.
I'M VERY IMPRESSED.
YOU'RE COMING BACK IN HERE,
LEARNING FROM THINGS,
BUILDING YOUR BUSINESS
THAT BIG IN JUST A YEAR.
IT'S THE POWER
OF "SHARK TANK."
I THINK IT'S THE POWER
OF YOU.
I LOVE PEOPLE
THAT LEARN FROM THEIR MISTAKES,
BUT THERE'S ONE
LITTLE PROBLEM I HAVE.
BECAUSE I'M NOT
A BIG MEAT EATER,
I DON'T THINK
I'M THE BEST PARTNER
TO GO INTO BUSINESS WITH YOU.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
Cuban: DAVE,
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT --
DOES IT MAKE SENSE
TO SPLIT THE BUSINESS?
I'M NOT SURE IT DOES.
O'Leary: OKAY, I'M GONNA MAKE
YOU AN OFFER. HERE IT IS.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
THE $150,000 FOR 20%.
I HAVE ONE OTHER COVENANT.
I WANT YOU TO SELL MY WICKED
GOOD CUPCAKES ON YOUR SITE.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA DO IT
FOR FREE.
I WANT AN ALLOCATION
OF THEIR PROFITS TO YOU, TOO,
AND THAT HAS TO BE WORKED OUT
WITH THEM AS ENTREPRENEURS.
SURE.
SO MY OFFER, IN SUMMARY,
IS THIS --
I WILL GIVE YOU THE $150,000
FOR 20% OF THE WHOLE BUSINESS,
AND I WANT MY WICKED CUPCAKES
ON YOUR SITE.
Herjavec: WHOA.
WAIT A MINUTE.
THE WHOLE BUSINESS.
THE WHOLE BUSINESS?
YEP.
OH.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO SPLIT
YOUR BUSINESS UP.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
DAVE, I'LL GIVE YOU $300,000
FOR 35%.
FOR THE WHOLE COMPANY?
A PIECE OF EVERYTHING?
THE WHOLE STRUCTURE.
ROBERT,
$300,000 FOR 35%?
KEVIN IS $150,000
FOR 20%.
O'Leary:
I MAY MODIFY MY OFFER.
I'LL PAY YOU $150,000
FOR 17.5%,
WHICH I THINK MATCHES
ROBERT'S VALUATION.
YEP.
BUT I STILL WANT
MY CUPCAKES ON YOUR SITE.
OF BOTH BUSINESS COMBINED?
YES, YES, YES.
HE'S OFFERING THE SAME VALUE
I AM, JUST LESS CASH.
BUT HE DOESN'T HAVE TO GIVE UP
AS MUCH OF HIS FAMILY BUSINESS.
HOW DO YOU ALLOCATE
YOUR TIME
BETWEEN THE TWO DIFFERENT
COMPANIES?
YOU PRIORITIZE IT,
IS WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO.
YOU SURROUND YOURSELF
WITH GREAT EMPLOYEES,
WHICH IS WHAT I'VE DONE,
AND YOU START TO DELEGATE.
MARK, ARE YOU INTERESTED
IN MAKING AN OFFER?
SO, I'LL GIVE YOU $150,000 FOR
25% OF YOUR MAIL-ORDER BUSINESS,
AND I WANT AN OPTION TO BUY
25% OF THE OTHER BUSINESS
FOR THE SAME $150,000.
IF EVERYTHING YOU SAY IS RIGHT
AND THE RETAIL BUSINESS
NOT REALLY AN IMPACT, GREAT.
IF IT TURNS OUT
YOU'RE SPLITTING YOUR TIME
OR SOMETHING TAKES YOUR TIME,
THAN I HAVE THAT OPTION.
SO, THAT'S MY OFFER.
BUT I WANT TO KNOW NOW.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
MARK, YOU HAVE A DEAL.
DONE.
WOW.
[ CHUCKLES ] 'CAUSE YOU KNOW
I'LL JUST EAT MY MONEY'S WORTH.
[ LAUGHS ]
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU, DAVE.
LOOK FORWARD TO IT.
THANKS, DAVE.
CONGRATULATIONS, MAN.
THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME BACK.
I'M A FAN.
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
Alwan: LAST TIME,
I FELT I BLEW AN OPPORTUNITY.
I WENT BACK,
CORRECTED MY MISTAKES,
AND IT FEELS ABSOLUTELY AMAZING
TO GET A DEAL ON "SHARK TANK"
AND TO HAVE MARK CUBAN
AS A PARTNER.
DOESN'T GET ANY BETTER
THAN THAT.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS AN ACCESSORY COMPANY
FOR WHAT THE ENTREPRENEUR HOPES
WILL BE A HUGE NEW TREND.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS BRIAN LIN.
I'M THE FOUNDER AND C.E.O.
OF THE EmazingLights.
TODAY WE'RE ASKING FOR $650,000
FOR 5% OF OUR COMPANY.
WOW.
SHARKS, PREPARE TO EXPERIENCE
THE LATEST DANCE CRAZE,
CALLED GLOVING.
OH, AND MR. WONDERFUL,
WE'RE GONNA BE BORROWING YOUR
HEART FOR THIS PERFORMANCE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
IF YOU CAN FIND IT.
[ LAUGHS ]
[ CHUCKLES ]
[ ELECTRONIC DANCE MUSIC PLAYS ]
♪ FACE MELT ♪
[ CHUCKLES ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
COOL.
EXCELLENT.
VERY COOL.
THANK YOU
FOR THE PERFORMANCE, GUYS.
SHARKS, IT'S YOUR TURN
TO JOIN THE GLOVING MOVEMENT.
GUMMY, COULD YOU PLEASE,
UH, GIVE BACK
MR. WONDERFUL HIS HEART?
HE MIGHT BE NEEDING IT.
[ CHUCKLES ] THANK --
OH, I FEEL WARM AND FUZZY.
LILI'S GONNA BE
HANDING OUT
YOUR OWN PERSONALIZED
eLITE CHROMA GLOVE SETS.
Herjavec: BRIAN,
DOES OURS CHANGE COLOR?
IF YOU MOVE IT, ROBERT,
YOU'LL SEE YOUR COLORS.
OH, WOW!
Greiner: YOURS CHANGES
WHEN YOU DO THIS?
YEAH, SO DOES YOURS.
EVERYONE'S CHANGES.
THAT'S COOL.
YOU CAN HAVE
UP TO 50 MODES,
AND YOU CAN CHOOSE
ANY OF THE 20 COLORS
IN ANY COMBINATION
OR ORDER THAT YOU LIKE.
SHARKS, GLOVING
IS ALREADY MOVING
FROM A SUBCULTURE
TO POP CULTURE.
O'Leary: SO, BRIAN,
HOW BIG IS GLOVING A MARKET,
BECAUSE YOU'VE IMPUTED A VALUE
ON GLOVING OF $13 MILLION,
'CAUSE YOU'VE ASKED ME
FOR $650,000 FOR 5%.
THAT IS A VERY BIG NUMBER,
AND I'M GONNA ASSUME
YOU HAVE SOME INCREDIBLE SALES
TO GET ME EXCITED ABOUT IT.
SINCE WE'VE STARTED
ABOUT FOUR YEARS AGO,
WE'VE GROSSED
OVER $13 MILLION.
WOW.
IN THIS CALENDAR YEAR,
HOW MUCH WILL YOU SELL?
WE'RE PROJECTED FOR $5.5
MILLION, AND WE ARE ON TARGET.
JUST GLOVES?
GLOVES IS
OUR PRIMARY PRODUCT.
WE'VE CREATED
SOME ANCILLARY PRODUCTS
WITH THE PATENT-PENDING
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE,
BUT IT ACTUALLY GETS
BETTER THAN THAT, SHARKS.
I'VE TAKEN PROFITS
FROM EmazingLights,
WHICH I BOOTSTRAPPED
WITH $100,
AND I'VE CREATED ANOTHER COMPANY
CALLED iHeartRaves.
iHeartRaves CATERS
TO ALL THE FESTIVAL GOERS
AND PROVIDES ALL THE AWESOME,
WILD APPAREL.
iHeartRaves, IN 2013,
MADE OVER $1.4 MILLION,
AND THIS YEAR, WE'RE ON
STATE FOR $2.5 MILLION.
AND THESE TWO BUSINESS,
YOU'RE SELLING TOGETHER, RIGHT?
YES.
Herjavec: SO, JUST TO BE CLEAR,
YOU'RE SELLING BOTH,
AND IT'S $8 MILLION
IN SALES?
CORRECT.
WHOA.
THAT'S CLEVER.
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
MY PARENTS IMMIGRATED HERE
TO ESCAPE COMMUNISM FROM CHINA.
GROWING UP AND SEEING THEM
WORK 18-HOUR DAYS
REALLY, REALLY HURT ME
AND JUST GAVE ME
THAT STRONG WORK ETHIC,
AND I DIDN'T WANT TO THROW AWAY
WHAT THEY HAD PROVIDED ME,
IN TERMS OF AN EDUCATION
IN THE U.S.
MARK, JUST LIKE YOU,
WHERE, INSTEAD OF SELLING
GARBAGE BAGS DOOR TO DOOR,
I WAS BURNING CDs
AND SELLING THOSE.
I'VE ALWAYS KNOWN I WANTED
TO BE AN ENTREPRENEUR.
DIDN'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT THE PRODUCT AND
SERVICE WAS GONNA BE.
FUNNY STORY -- MY GIRLFRIEND
ACTUALLY GOT ME INTO GLOVING.
I GAVE MY FIRST LIGHT SHOW,
AND I FELL IN LOVE,
BECAUSE I WAS ATTRACTING
CROWDS OF PEOPLE AROUND ME.
I'VE NEVER HAD
THAT FEELING BEFORE,
AND I WANTED TO SHARE THAT
WITH THE WORLD.
SO, THIS IS NOT PATENTED.
WE HAVE A PATENT PENDING,
AND THAT PATENT
IS PRIMARILY ON THE PROGRAMMING
METHOD OF THE LIGHTS.
SO OTHER PEOPLE
MAKE GLOVES WITH LIGHTS.
SOMEBODY ELSE COULD
MAKE GLOVES WITH LIGHTS,
BUT HOW MANY
OTHER PEOPLE ARE?
WE OWN 80%
OF THE GLOBAL GLOVING MARKET.
THE REST OF THE MARKET
IS MADE UP OF FOUR OR FIVE
OF OUR COMPETITORS,
AND I GUARANTEE YOU THAT THEY DO
NOT OPERATE AT THE SAME LEVEL.
HEY, LOOK.
NO, WHAT YOU'VE DONE IS AMAZING.
YOU KNOW, I LOVE TO CLAP
FOR ENTREPRENEURS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
TO GO FROM $100
TO, YOU KNOW, HERE YOU ARE.
THE CHALLENGE, THOUGH, IS --
AND YOU KNOW IT --
THERE'S A VERY GOOD CHANCE
THAT IT'S TRANSIENT...
RIGHT.
...THAT -- THAT IT'S A FAD.
BUT YOU CAN MAKE A LOT OF MONEY
BY MAKING SOMETHING A NICHE.
THERE'S -- JUST LOOK AT
THE GAMING INDUSTRY.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
HAVE BECOME BIG NICHES, RIGHT?
RIGHT.
SO WHAT'S ONE OF THESE
GONNA COST ME?
ARE GLOVES RANGE FROM $20
FOR THE ENTRY LEVEL
ALL THE WAY UP TO $120,
WHICH IS THE eLITE CHROMAS
THAT YOU GUYS HAVE.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
$20 MODEL AND THE $120?
PROGRAMMABILITY.
YOU CAN CUSTOMIZE THE COLORS
TO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
YOU CAN CUSTOMIZE
THE MODE.
WHAT'S YOUR MARGIN?
WHAT'S IT COST TO MAKE?
MARGIN RANGES
FROM $10 TO $17.
ARE YOU MAKING THIS
YOURSELF?
YES, WE DESIGNED IT,
DID ALL THE TOOLING
AND PROTOTYPING OVERSEAS.
WE HAVE GREAT CONNECTIONS
WITH OVER 20 FACTORIES.
SO, STRATEGICALLY,
WHAT DO YOU SEE NEXT?
I AM THE MOST EXCITED
ABOUT THE SPORT OF GLOVING.
THE SPORT?
IT'S BECOME
A PROFESSIONAL SPORT.
SO, INTERNATIONAL GLOVING
CHAMPIONSHIP
HAS BEEN DEVELOPED BY US.
WE'VE CREATED THE RULES,
WE'VE CREATED THE JUDGES,
WE'VE CREATED THE FORMAT.
THEY COMPETE HEAD TO HEAD.
WHAT IS THE ESSENCE
OF THE SPORT?
LIKE, HOW DO I WIN?
Cuban: IT'S A PERFORMANCE.
WHOEVER PUTS ON THE BEST
PERFORMANCE, RIGHT?
EXACTLY.
BASICALLY, THIS IS
BREAK DANCING...
BREAK DANCING WITH A GREAT
PRODUCT TO FUND IT.
THAT YOU CAN SELL, YEAH.
THAT YOU CAN SELL.
WHEN BREAK DANCING
CAME OUT,
THIS IS BASICALLY THE FEEL
AND THE ENERGY OF THAT.
IT'S AN UNDERGROUND SWELL.
EXACTLY.
THERE ARE CREWS,
YOU KNOW, AGAINST CREWS.
THERE ARE FANS.
BRIAN, YOU'RE CREATING
YOUR OWN INDUSTRY.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT GLOVING IS
THAT IT'S NOT GENRE-SPECIFIC.
IT HAS GROWN
OUT OF THE EDM SCENE,
BUT IT'S GROWING INTO HIP-HOP
AND ALL OTHER TYPES OF MUSIC.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS ANYONE
THAT SEES GLOVING
THINKS
IT'S AUTOMATICALLY COOL.
IT'S NOW MY JOB TO GET IT IN
FRONT OF MILLIONS OF EYEBALLS,
AND I'M VERY,
VERY CONFIDENT
THAT WE CAN BUILD GLOVING
INTO A BILLION-DOLLAR INDUSTRY.
Herjavec: BRIAN, IT'S BRILLIANT.
IT'S SUCH A GREAT IDEA.
YOU WENT OUT
AND CREATED A COMPETITION
TO CREATE THE DEMAND FOR IT.
IT'S FANTASTIC.
TELL ME -- HOW DO YOU SELL
THE PRODUCT TODAY?
SO, ABOUT 90%
WOULD BE ONLINE.
WE HAVE TWO RETAIL STORES
OURSELVES,
AND WE NOW HAVE THREE
LICENSED STORES, AND WE'RE --
SO, NOW THE GOAL IS,
IF YOU'RE GONNA BE A
BILLION-DOLLAR COMPANY,
YOU HAVE TO EXPAND REGIONALLY
AND, REALLY, GLOBALLY.
JAPAN IS DEFINITELY
A BIG MARKET FOR US NOW.
AUSTRALIA'S
GETTING INTO IT.
I FEEL LIKE I AM THE LID
ON OUR GROWTH.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR HIRING PROCESS
KEEPS THE BAD PEOPLE OUT
AND I ONLY BRING IN PEOPLE
THAT HAVE A TRUE PASSION
FOR WHAT WE'RE DOING.
O'Leary: ALL RIGHT.
SO, BRIAN,
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'M GONNA STRUCTURE IT
IN A WAY THAT --
HE JUST SAID HE WANTS TO KEEP
THE BAD PEOPLE OUT.
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT'S WHY
I'M A GOOD PEOPLE.
IN MY VIEW, THE TRANSIENT NATURE
OF IT HAS ME A LITTLE NERVOUS.
BUT I CAN SEE SOMEONE HERE
WHO'S WORKING HIS TAIL OFF,
WHICH IS INTERESTING.
THE DIVERSITY
AND DIVERSIFICATION
OF REVENUE STREAMS
IS OF INTEREST TO ME
'CAUSE THAT
DIVERSIFIES RISK.
I'M GONNA LOAN YOU
$650,000.
I'M GONNA ASK
FOR 3% EQUITY,
BUT IT'LL GIVE YOU
THE FUNDS YOU NEED TO GROW.
KEVIN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OFFER,
BUT I WILL
HAVE TO DECLINE.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT WHY
I'M HERE TODAY.
I'M LOOKING TO GET ONE OF
YOU SHARKS ON MY TEAM
TO HELP US
WITH THE DAY TO DAY.
SO, YOU DON'T WANT TO DO ANY
DEBT, IS WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
I'VE NEVER GONE OUT AND LOOKED
FOR A LOAN FOR THIS COMPANY.
OKAY. I'M OUT.
SO, WHY IS THE OFFER
SO SMALL?
BECAUSE IF YOU WANT ONE OF US
TO GET OUT OF BED IN THE MORNING
TO COME WORK WITH YOU...
MM-HMM.
...WHY WOULD WE DO THAT
FOR 5%?
THE 5% WAS BECAUSE I'M NOT
REALLY LOOKING FOR THE MONEY.
I THINK YOU GUYS ARE
THE SMARTEST BUSINESSPEOPLE
ON THE PLANET.
YOU KNOW, WHY DON'T
YOU GUYS TELL ME
WHAT PERCENTAGE MAKES SENSE
FOR YOU
TO JUMP INTO BED WITH US
AND GROW THIS INTO
A BILLION-DOLLAR INDUSTRY?
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
AN OFFER.
I WANT TO HELP YOU
WITH ALL THE LICENSING.
I CAN GET YOU
THE MARVELS OF THE WORLD,
AND I CAN GET YOU INTO
THE SPENCER'S AND PARTY CITYS,
IF THAT'S YOUR OBJECTIVE,
AND THE OTHER
BRAND EXTENSIONS.
I'LL GIVE YOU $650,000
FOR...
...20% OF THE LICENSING
THAT I BRING TO YOU.
Herjavec:
AND NOT THE COMPANY.
SO, NOT THE COMPANY.
THAT IS NOT
OF YOUR COMPANY.
I WILL GO OUT
AND GET YOU THE LICENSES.
I TAKE 20%.
I DON'T WANT ANY EQUITY.
ALL RIGHT, BRIAN.
LOOK, YOU'RE THE REAL DEAL, MAN.
LIKE, YOU ARE PROBABLY
ONE OF THE, IF NOT THE,
BEST ENTREPRENEUR
WE'VE EVER HAD HERE,
AND I THINK YOU NEED
SOME HELP WITH GROWTH.
HERE'S THE OFFER THAT LORI AND I
WANT TO MAKE YOU.
WE WANT TO HELP YOU.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE TWO PEOPLE.
IN THE TRENCHES
TOGETHER.
RIGHT.
I THINK YOU GOT TO LICENSE IT.
THAT'S OKAY,
BUT I DON'T THINK YOU NEED TO
GIVE UP 20% TO LICENSE IT.
YOU CAN DO THAT
THROUGH THE BUSINESS.
YOU CAN WORK OUT
THOSE DEALS --
OH, NO. YOU CAN'T.
IT'S NOT THAT EASY.
NOT THAT EASY.
WELL, HERE'S THE OFFER.
BRIAN,
ONCE YOU GET BIGGER,
YOU CAN DO BETTER
LICENSING DEALS THAN TODAY,
SO WHY COMMIT
FOR THAT TODAY?
LORI AND I WOULD LIKE
TO OFFER YOU $1 MILLION
FOR 8% STRAIGHT-UP
EQUITY.
Cuban: OKAY, SO HERE'S
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO --
THE 650 GRAND, RIGHT,
5%, AND I'LL BE INVOLVED
ON THE STRATEGIC SIDE.
WE'LL DO A HALFTIME
WITH THE MAVS.
WE'LL TURN DOWN THE LIGHTS,
WE'LL LET YOU DO A PERFORMANCE
SO THAT YOU CAN OPEN UP
TO DALLAS. THAT'S EASY.
AND THEN DAYMOND,
AS PART OF THAT,
LIKE HE INTRODUCED EARLIER,
IS GONNA TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE LICENSING
AND EARN A 20% COMMISSION
FOR WHAT HE LICENSES.
THAT'S THE OFFER.
OKAY.
SO, YOU HAVE THE SPORTS GUY AND
THE KIND OF MUSIC FASHION GUY
WHO'S GONNA WORK
WITH YOU,
OR YOU HAVE THE QUEEN OF QVC
AND THE SECURITY GUY.
WAIT A MINUTE. I'M IN RETAIL
EVERYWHERE AND INTERNATIONALLY.
LISTEN TO ME RIGHT NOW.
I CAN GET YOU INTO AN ARENA.
I WORK WITH LIVE NATION.
WE ALL DO IT.
LORI AND I WANT TO BE INVOLVED.
WE'RE GONNA CHANGE OUR OFFER.
MY FRIEND, WE WANT TO BE
PART OF YOUR TEAM.
$1 MILLION FOR 5%.
THAT'S A SERIOUS OFFER.
I'M GONNA SAY ONE THING.
WHO WOULD YOU
HANG OUT WITH?
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
NO, WAIT.
UGH.
THE ONE THING THAT YOU SAID WAS,
IT WASN'T ABOUT THE MONEY.
RIGHT?
IT WAS ABOUT
THE EXPERIENCE
AND IT WAS ABOUT THE GUIDANCE
AND IT WAS ABOUT THE SUPPORT.
RIGHT.
RIGHT?
THEY KEEP ON RESPONDING
BASED OFF THE MONEY.
NO, THAT'S CRAP.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THAT'S NOT TRUE AT ALL.
SO, YOU GOT TO MAKE
A CALL, BRIAN.
BRIAN, YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE
THE DECISION.
$20 MILLION VALUATION.
$13 MILLION.
YOU UNDERSTAND
THE OFFERS?
YES, I DO.
WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO DO?
Narrator:
ONE SHARK IS OUT.
BRIAN HAS TWO OFFERS
ON THE TABLE
FOR HIS LIGHTED-GLOVE COMPANY
EmazingLights.
MARK AND DAYMOND HAVE OFFERED
$650,000 FOR 5% EQUITY
AND 20% OF ANY LICENSING DEALS
THAT DAYMOND FINDS.
AND ROBERT AND LORI
HAVE OFFERED $1 MILLION
FOR 5% EQUITY IN THE COMPANY.
BRIAN, YOU'VE GOT
TO MAKE A DECISION.
$20 MILLION VALUATION.
$13 MILLION.
YOU UNDERSTAND
THE OFFERS?
YES, I DO.
WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO?
UM...I-I HOLD TRUE
TO IT'S NOT ABOUT THE MONEY.
THE VALUATION DIFFERENCE
DOES NOT REALLY MATTER TO ME
RIGHT NOW.
I'M LOOKING
AT THE NON-CASH VALUE
AND WHAT YOU GUYS
CAN BRING TO THE TABLE.
I-IT'S VERY, VERY HARD
TO DENY, DAYMOND,
THE BRANDS THAT YOU HAVE BUILT
FROM THE GROUND UP.
LORI, I'VE HEARD STORIES
OF YOUR WORK ETHIC,
AND IT'S JUST MIND-BLOWING.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I -- UM...
BRIAN, FOCUS. DECIDE.
WHAT'S IN YOUR GUT?
LORI, ROBERT, I KNOW I WOULD
DO VERY WELL WITH YOU GUYS.
MARK, DAYMOND, I WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE YOU GUYS AS MY PARTNER.
LET'S DO IT.
HIGH-FIVE, BABY!
YEAH!
OH!
THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME, GUYS.
UNBELIEVABLE.
I GOT TO TELL YOU --
I HATE LOSING THAT ONE.
YOU NEVER SEE A VALUE LIKE THAT
IN THE TANK.
Lin: I CANNOT BELIEVE WHAT
JUST HAPPENED IN THE TANK.
I MEAN, IT'S MY WILDEST DREAM
COME TRUE.
I'M GONNA GET TO WORK
WITH DAYMOND AND MARK CUBAN.
I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE
WHAT MY WORKWEEK'S GONNA
LOOK LIKE ANYMORE.
I'M SO EXCITED.
Narrator:
EARLIER THIS SEASON,
WE SAW SIBLINGS
JEFF AND JEN MARTIN
MAKE A DEAL
WITH BARBARA CORCORAN
FOR THEIR MINI-POPCORN COMPANY
PIPCORN.
$200,000 FOR 10%.
ARE YOU
OUT OF YOUR MIND?!
Narrator: LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
Jeff: AFTER AIRING,
WE HAD ABOUT 12,000 ORDERS,
WHICH IS ABOUT 11,000 MORE
THAN WE'VE EVER HAD BEFORE.
IN YEAR LEADING UP
TO "SHARK TANK,"
WE HAD $200,000 IN SALES.
IN LESS THAN THREE MONTHS
SINCE WE CLOSED OUR DEAL,
WE HAVE OVER $1.1 MILLION
IN SALES.
HEY, JEFF, JEN!
HEY!
Jeff: BARBARA WARNED US OF HUGE
SALES AFTER "SHARK TANK,"
BUT WE WEREN'T QUITE READY
FOR THE VOLUME.
WE WOUND UP IN A BIT
OF A BACK-ORDER SITUATION.
I'M ACTUALLY HAPPY
IT HAPPENED
SO THAT WE NEVER HAVE
THIS PROBLEM AGAIN.
Corcoran:
THE PROBLEM WITH BACK ORDERS
IS YOU CAN LOSE A LOT
OF VALUABLE CUSTOMERS.
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE TO WAIT.
WE WERE HONEST,
TOLD THEM WHAT WAS HAPPENING,
AND THE PEOPLE
THAT WAITED THE LONGEST,
WE GAVE 50% OFF AND FREE
SHIPPING ON THE NEXT ORDER.
IT TOOK US TWO MONTHS TO FULFILL
ALL THE ORDERS, BUT WE DID IT.
AND NOW WE HAVE
A BIGGER BUSINESS.
YEAH.
CO-PACKERS HERE, THERE,
AND EVERYWHERE.
NOW WE HAVE CO-PACKERS IN
THE MIDWEST, ON THE WEST COAST.
WE CAN SELL AS MUCH PIPCORN
AS THE CUSTOMERS WILL HAVE.
GUYS, I'M JUST SO PROUD
OF EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S THE BEAUTY
OF "SHARK TANK."
YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE.
DID I EVER THINK I'D BE
INVESTING IN A POPCORN BUSINESS?
OF COURSE NOT, BUT HERE I AM
AT PIPCORN MAKING MONEY.
WHOA.
THERE IT IS.
WE STARTED IN A POT
AT A FARMERS' MARKET.
NEXT STOP...
NATIONWIDE.
IT'S TRULY AN AMAZING STORY
THAT WE ACTUALLY ARE LIVING,
AND EVERY DAY, WE'RE JUST
SO HAPPY TO BE DOING IT.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A WAY TO MAKE TRIPS
TO THE BEACH OR POOL WORRY-FREE.
HELLO, SHARKS.
I'M ROB.
I'M JONATHAN.
AND I'M AVIN.
WE'RE THE INVENTORS
OF THE AquaVault.
WE'RE SEEKING
A $75,000 INVESTMENT
FOR 12% OF OUR COMPANY.
IF YOU'RE AT THE BEACH,
THE POOL, OR THE WATER PARK,
AND YOU WANT TO GO
FOR A SWIM,
WHAT DO YOU DO
WITH YOUR VALUABLES?
WE'VE ALL BEEN THERE.
ROBERT, DO YOU TUCK THEM
IN YOUR SHOES?
LORI, DO YOU ASK
THE SKETCHY GUY NEXT TO YOU
TO KEEP AN EYE
ON YOUR STUFF?
MR. WONDERFUL,
ARE YOU CONSTANTLY LOOKING BACK
OVER YOUR SHOULDER
EVERY COUPLE OF MINUTES?
NOT ANYMORE.
Kinas:
INTRODUCING THE AquaVault --
A SIMPLE AND STYLISH
PORTABLE VAULT
TO SECURE YOUR VALUABLES
SO YOU CAN ENJOY THE SUN
WITHOUT GETTING BURNED.
JUST SET YOUR CODE,
INSERT YOUR VALUABLES,
CLAMP DOWN
OVER ANY FIXED OBJECT.
NOW YOU CAN STOP WORRYING
THAT SOMEONE'S SNOOPING AROUND,
READY TO GRAB
YOUR BELONGINGS.
JUST LOCK UP
AND GO FOR A WORRY-FREE SWIM.
Samtani:
SHARKS, WE NEED YOUR HELP
TO TAKE US TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
WHO WANTS TO LOCK UP
AND SWIM WITH US?
Herjavec:
I THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA.
I'M ALWAYS DOING THIS.
SOMEONE'S ALWAYS GOT TO
STAY BY THE TOWEL.
WHAT DO YOU
SELL IT FOR?
IT RETAILS FOR $39.95,
WHOLESALE FOR $22.95.
WE MAKE THEM FOR $10.86.
WE'VE ONLY DONE ONE ORDER
WITH THE FACTORY.
IT WAS A 5,000-UNIT ORDER, WHICH
WAS THE MINIMUM ORDER, SO...
O'Leary: SO, GUYS, TALK TO ME
ABOUT YOUR BUSINESS MODEL.
I'VE ACTUALLY SEEN
YOUR COMPETITOR.
YOU HAVE?
YES.
I'VE BEEN PITCHED
THEIR DEAL.
SO, TELL US ABOUT
YOUR BUSINESS MODEL.
SO, RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE
A FEW DIFFERENT MODELS.
WE'RE TARGETING HOTELS DIRECTLY,
CRUISE SHIPS, THEME PARKS.
WE'RE ACTUALLY IN A MAJORITY
OF THE HOTELS
ON SOUTH BEACH RIGHT NOW
ON THE BEACH.
TELL US THE NUMBERS.
YEAR TO DATE,
WE'VE DONE $87,000 SALES.
THAT JUST STARTED
SIX MONTHS AGO.
WE HAVE A CONTRACT FOR ANOTHER
1,000 UNITS BY YEAR END,
SO WE'RE GONNA BREAK $100,000
WITHIN OUR FIRST YEAR.
YOU SELL THE HOTEL OR LEASE
THE SPACE FROM THE HOTEL
FOR THE UNITS AND CHARGE
THE CUSTOMERS ON THEIR BILL?
HOW DO I GET PAID?
Samtani: KEVIN,
WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS WE'RE SELLING THE UNIT
TO THE HOTELS
FOR OUR WHOLESALE PRICE.
THEY'RE THEN RENTING IT OUT
TO EACH GUEST
BETWEEN $5 AND $10 A DAY.
OKAY. DO YOU GET ANY MONEY
OFF RENTING IT?
NOT JUST YET. NO.
HERE'S MY CHALLENGE.
WE DEAL WITH A LOT
OF HOTEL CHAINS.
THEY ARE
INCREDIBLY FRUGAL.
WHY NOT GIVE THEM
TO THE HOTELS
AND THEN TAKE A SHARE
IN THEIR RECURRING REVENUE?
'CAUSE I DO SEE THAT.
I THINK PEOPLE WOULD PAY $5
TO $10 A DAY.
WHY HAVEN'T YOU GONE THAT ROUTE?
WHAT AM I MISSING?
WE WERE JUST STARTING OUT,
AND AT THE SAME TIME,
A LOT OF HOTELS ARE
NOT GONNA WANT TO OPEN
UP THEIR BOOKS TO US
TO SHOW WHAT KIND OF REVENUE
THAT THEY'VE MADE.
THE WAY WE HAVE IT
RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE SELLING IT TO THEM
WHOLESALE,
THEY'RE GETTING
THEIR R.O.I. BACK --
YEAH, AND PLUS YOU GET
YOUR CASH BACK RIGHT AWAY.
ABSOLUTELY.
RIGHT.
SO, WE HAVE
THREE DIFFERENT MODELS
WHICH WE'D LIKE
TO REALLY DO.
THE HOTEL PURCHASES
AT WHOLESALE PRICE.
THEY THEN
RENT IT OUT DAILY.
THE OTHER MODEL WOULD BE
THE GIFT-SHOP MODEL.
THE THIRD MODEL
IS THE IDEAL MODEL --
HAVE THEM
IN EVERY SINGLE ROOM,
ABOVE THE ACTUAL SAFES,
INSIDE THE ROOM,
SHRINK-WRAPPED,
WITH A POINT-OF-SALE SIGN.
THAT IS TOUGH.
MAYBE A "TAKE ME
WITH YOU" SIGN.
THAT'S REALLY HARD.
YEAH, THAT'S TOUGH.
PEOPLE IN VEGAS AND RESORTS,
THINGS LIKE THAT --
BEFORE YOU GO DOWN
TO THE POOL,
YOU'RE GONNA PUT YOUR STUFF
IN THE SAFE.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA.
BUT YOU'RE JUST GONNA
USE THE SAFE THAT'S
ALREADY IN THE HOTEL.
BUT WE LIVE IN A DAY
AND AGE RIGHT NOW
WHERE PEOPLE WANT THEIR
SMARTPHONES WITH THEM.
I THINK
THAT'S A GREAT IDEA.
YOU KNOW, I...
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $75,000 FOR 25%.
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THAT OFFER.
25% IS A LITTLE HIGH
FOR US.
YOU HAVE NO OTHER OFFERS.
IS THERE ANY WAY
THAT WE CAN OPEN UP
TO SEE IF ANYONE ELSE
WANTS TO PARTICIPATE?
Samtani:
THERE ARE THREE OF US.
YOU KNOW, WE'VE LEFT
OUR CAREERS TO DO THIS.
GUYS, I MADE YOU AN OFFER.
$75,000 FOR 25%.
I DON'T MIND,
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE RUDE,
TO LISTEN IF THERE
WAS OTHER OFFERS,
BUT I DON'T WANT TO WAIT
FOR OTHER SHARK TANK TRASH TALK,
SO $75,000, 25%.
I DON'T HEAR ANY OTHER OFFERS
COMING. I HEAR A LOT OF TALK.
I WANT TO JUST ASK
ONE MORE QUESTION,
AND THEN MAYBE
I'LL BE INTERESTED OR NOT.
EXACTLY MY POINT.
GOT TO GET MY INFORMATION.
IS IT ONLY IN MIAMI
WHERE YOU'RE SELLING,
OR ARE YOU SELLING ONLINE,
AS WELL?
WELL, RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE SELLING IT
WHERE WE GOT THE, YOU KNOW,
HOTELS IN MIAMI.
WE HAVE HSN.
WE HAVE A FEW CATALOGS.
YOU'VE BEEN ON HSN?
CORRECT.
Greiner:
HOW DID IT DO?
AND HOW DID THAT GO?
THEY PURCHASED
850 UNITS FROM US,
AND WE ALSO JUST FILLED
A PURCHASE ORDER
FROM TVSN
IN AUSTRALIA.
YOU GUYS ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THEM, RIGHT?
HOW DID THE, UM --
DID THEY ALL SELL OUT ON HSN?
WE SOLD 200 UNITS.
OH, REALLY.
John: LORI, HOW WAS
THAT PERFORMANCE?
GIVE ME THE ADVICE
'CAUSE THIS IS YOUR WORLD.
WELL, IT WASN'T
A GOOD PERFORMANCE.
THEY KNOW THAT.
OKAY, GUYS, WHAT ARE
YOU DOING ONLINE?
SO, RIGHT NOW, IT'S JUST BEEN
RELENTLESS REACHING OUT
TO THE P.R. OUTLETS,
MEDIA,
YOU KNOW, BLOGGERS,
MAGAZINE ARTICLES.
WE WERE FEATURED
ON THE "TODAY" SHOW,
WHICH DEFINITELY HELPED
TO GET OUR ORDERS UP,
BUT I'D SAY WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING
MORE ON THE COMMERCIAL END,
SO IT'S REALLY BEEN
AN 80/20 SPLIT.
YEAH, BUT IF YOU'RE GETTING
ALL THIS P.R.,
YOU WOULD THINK THERE WOULD BE
CARRYOVER ONLINE, RIGHT?
THERE DEFINITELY HAS.
HOW MANY UNITS
HAVE YOU SOLD ONLINE?
WE'VE SOLD ROUGHLY...
250.
...250.
WHOA.
WOW. THAT'S LOW.
BUT WAIT, WAIT.
THIS IS MORE OF A COMMERCIAL
PRODUCT IN OUR EYES.
IT WAS IN FOUR MONTHS,
RIGHT?
THAT'S LOW, GUYS.
MAYBE
THERE'S A PROBLEM.
WE HAVE -- WE HAVE
1,000 OTHER ONLINE VENDORS
SELLING THE PRODUCT RIGHT NOW,
OTHER THAN OUR WEBSITE.
Greiner: SO, WHAT WAS THE TOTAL
SALES THAT YOU DID?
$87,000.
IN SIX MONTHS.
$33,000 WAS HOTELS,
OF THAT.
$33,000 WAS THE HOTELS.
EVERYTHING ELSE
WAS DONE THROUGH --
AND THE REST WAS ONLINE.
Herjavec: ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
I'VE HEARD ENOUGH.
THE MORE I HEARD,
THE MORE PROBLEMS I-I HEARD.
UM...
YOU GOT TO UNDERSTAND,
WE'RE NEW AT THIS.
WE REALLY JUST STARTED.
YEAH, I HEAR YOU,
BUT I HEAR MORE, UH, PROBLEMS
THAN I SEE OPPORTUNITY.
I'M OUT.
O'Leary:
OOH, LOOK AT THAT.
ONE MOMENT IT WAS THERE,
AND THEN, POOF, IT'S GONE.
THAT HAPPENS
IN THE SHARK TANK SOMETIMES.
YOU TALK TOO MUCH,
YOU CAN'T KEEP YOUR MOUTH SHUT,
AND YOU LOSE A DEAL.
HAVE YOU SOLD
TO ANY OF THE WATER PARKS?
YES.
Samtani: YES.
WE'RE ACTUALLY AT THE RAPIDS
WATER PARK IN SOUTH FLORIDA.
WE'RE IN TALKS WITH WET 'N WILD
AND TYPHOON LAGOON RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE A DEAL WITH HSN,
AND I CAN BRING THE COSTS DOWN.
HERE'S MY OFFER --
$75,000 FOR 25%, AS WELL.
BUT I NEED THE ANSWER NOW.
LOOK, I LIKE DEALS
THAT ARE BIGGER
BECAUSE THEY CAN GET BIGGER.
IT'S A NICE PRODUCT --
GUYS, HE ALWAYS DOES THIS,
AND THEN HE JUMPS IN.
GIVE ME
A YES OR NO RIGHT NOW.
[ SIGHS ]
DAYMOND,
WE HAVE A DEAL.
ALL RIGHT.
SMART MAN.
THERE YOU GO.
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD STUFF.
THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
I REALLY LIKED IT
WHEN I FIRST SAW IT, DAYMOND.
ROBERT, ROBERT,
THESE GUYS WERE SO BUSY
TRYING TO GET IT OUT TO THE
BEACH AND DO ALL THAT STUFF,
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO
CONCENTRATE ON THOSE SALES.
THAT'S ALL IT IS.
I WAS REALLY SURPRISED
YOU DIDN'T SQUEEZE THEIR
HEAD A LITTLE HARDER.
Peck: NOW THAT WE HAVE
DAYMOND ON BOARD,
WE CAN GET OUR COSTS DOWN
AND GET THE AquaVault
OUT TO MORE RESORTS,
MORE PLACES THAN WE EVER THOUGHT
WE COULD BEFORE.
NICE!
WE DID IT.
CAME IN.
GOT THE DEAL.
CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
SO HAPPY.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS WHAT THE ENTREPRENEUR HOPES
WILL BE A DISRUPTIVE BRAND IN
A MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR INDUSTRY.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS CATALINA GIRALD,
AND I'M THE FOUNDER AND C.E.O.
OF NAJA.
I'M ASKING FOR $500,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 5% EQUITY
IN MY COMPANY.
WE THINK IT'S TIME
FOR A NEW LINGERIE BRAND.
AT NAJA,
WE'RE ACTUALLY MAKING PRODUCT
THAT'S BETTER THAN OTHER BRANDS
AT A FAIR PRICE, AND WE DO GOOD.
THROUGH OUR UNDERWEAR FOR HOPE
PROGRAM,
NAJA TRAINS AND EMPLOYS
SINGLE MOTHERS TO SEW
SO THAT YOU CAN
FEEL GOOD KNOWING
EVERY TIME THAT BUY A PRODUCT,
THAT YOU'RE HELPING
A WOMAN IN NEED.
NAJA IS DISRUPTING THE $14
BILLION U.S. LINGERIE INDUSTRY,
BUT BEFORE I GO
TO THE REST OF MY PITCH,
I'M GOING TO HAND OUT
SOME SAMPLES.
ROBERT.
I WILL NOT TRY IT ON.
[ CHUCKLES ]
YOURS IS THE DOG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LORI, YOURS IS
FROM OUR SPARROW COLLECTION,
WHICH IS MY FAVORITE.
OKAY.
MR. WONDERFUL, SINCE YOU'RE
THE SHARKIEST OF SHARKS,
I WENT THE OPPOSITE WAY,
AND YOURS IS THE KOALA
BECAUSE IT'S THE FURRIEST
AND HAPPIEST OF THEM ALL.
[ CHUCKLES ]
DAYMOND, YOU GET ONE
OF THE FIRST SAMPLES
FROM OUR NEW COLLECTION.
THANK YOU.
MARK, YOU GET
ROCKER GIRL BLUE
'CAUSE IT MATCHES
THE COLORS OF THE MAVS.
THAT WORKS.
Greiner: EACH ONE
HAVE A MESSAGE INSIDE?
THEY DO.
"I AM NOT WEIRD.
I AM LIMITED EDITION."
Herjavec: WELL, THIS IS CUTE.
"BE YOURSELF.
EVERYONE ELSE
IS ALREADY TAKEN."
MOST LINGERIE IS MADE FOR MEN,
AND IT'S MARKETED FOR MEN.
THIS IS FOR WOMEN,
SO WE PUT THE PRINTS
ON THE INTERIOR OF THE BRAS
BECAUSE IT'S FOR YOU.
SO, WHICH ONE OF YOU SHARKS
IS INTERESTED IN LEARNING MORE
AND JOINING ME IN CREATING
THE NEXT BIG LINGERIE BRAND?
TELL US ABOUT YOUR BUSINESS.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
SO, THEY'RE $145,000
IN ABOUT 5√ MONTHS.
WHAT DOES IT SELL FOR?
HOW DO YOU SELL IT?
SO, LET ME GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE.
THIS BRA SELLS FOR $60.
HOW MUCH DOES IT
COST YOU TO MAKE?
THAT PARTICULAR BRA IS $7.
OUR MARGINS ARE 72%.
WOW.
OKAY, THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
O'Leary: CAN I ASK,
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT,
WHY YOU THINK
AT THIS POINT
THIS BRAND, NAJA,
IS WORTH $10 MILLION?
WELL, IT HAS TO DO WITH HOW MUCH
MONEY WE'VE RAISED IN THE PAST.
WHY DO I CARE ABOUT THAT?
YOU KNOW,
I'M FROM SILICON VALLEY.
MARK'S FROM SILICON VALLEY.
HE KNOWS --
WELL, I GUESS HE'LL
GIVE YOU THE MONEY, THEN.
Herjavec: ALL RIGHT.
TELL US ABOUT THE VALUATION.
HOW MUCH MONEY
DID YOU RAISE?
SO, WE RAISED $850,000
AT $5 MILLION
PRE-MONEY VALUATION
ABOUT A YEAR AGO,
WHEN IT WAS JUST ON A NAPKIN.
WHY?
WHAT WAS
ON THE NAPKIN?
[ LAUGHS ]
I'M SORRY?
WHAT WAS ON THE NAPKIN?
THE PARTNER THAT
I HAD BEEN SPEAKING TO,
WHEN HE TALKED TO ME
ON THE PHONE FIRST,
'CAUSE HE DIDN'T
EVEN WANT A MEETING WITH ME,
HE SAID, "I'VE SEEN
SO MANY LINGERIE COMPANIES.
CHANCES ARE,
I'M GONNA SAY NO TO YOU."
I CONVINCED HIM,
AND WE ACTUALLY MET AT A BAR
OVER A GLASS OF WINE,
AND I SHOWED HIM
MY PROTOTYPES,
LIKE, JUST -- I HAD DRAWN.
I'M A DESIGNER,
BUT I'M AN MBA,
I'M A LAWYER,
ALL KINDS OF THINGS.
Cuban:
WHERE DID YOU GO TO SCHOOL?
STANFORD.
OF COURSE YOU DID.
LET ME UNDERSTAND THIS.
WHAT'S UNIQUE TO YOU?
THAT'S -- GETTING THERE.
THAT'S NOT
WHAT MAKES A BRAND.
WHAT MAKES A BRAND IS,
ONE, YOU NEED TO LOOK INTO
OUR MANUFACTURING PROCESSES.
SO, WHAT WE'RE DOING,
ON A SUPPLY-CHAIN LEVEL,
IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
ANYONE ELSE IS DOING.
WHAT YOU SEE
IN THE LINGERIE INDUSTRY
ARE THE LEAD TIMES
RIGHT NOW.
LEAD TIMES ARE OVER A YEAR.
YEAH, BUT A LOT OF THAT HAS
TO DO WITH SCALE, TOO.
UM, NO.
IT HAS TO DO
WITH HOW YOU BUY PRODUCT.
SO WE ACTUALLY OWN OUR OWN
SMALL MANUFACTURING FACILITY.
WE OWN OUR OWN SAMPLING
FACILITY.
WE OWN ALL
OF OUR RAW MATERIALS.
BECAUSE I ALREADY HAVE
THE RAW MATERIALS,
I CAN HAVE A COLLECTION
FROM CONCEPT INTO THE STORE
IN FOUR MONTHS,
BUT I CAN REMAKE A COLLECTION
IN TWO TO THREE WEEKS.
ALL RIGHT, BUT IN THIS BUSINESS
OF LINGERIE,
BRAND IS EVERYTHING.
AND I KNOW YOU SAY
YOU HAVE A BRAND,
BUT YOU DON'T REALLY
'CAUSE NO ONE KNOWS NAJA YET.
OH, NO. WE DO.
Herjavec:
CATALINA, YOU'RE NOT A BRAND.
YOU'RE STARTING OUT.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW YOU.
WHY IS THE BUSINESS WORTH
$10 MILLION? OR $9 MILLION?
BECAUSE SOM-- BECAUSE
SOMEONE ELSE SAID YES.
MARKET SETS THE PRICE.
COULD I TAKE A PORTION
OF $9 MILLION
AND EMULATE THIS
WITH SOMEBODY ELSE?
NO. NO.
WHY?
WELL, I DON'T
AGREE WITH YOU.
YOU'RE NOT INVESTING
IN MY COMPANY
BASED ON TODAY'S VALUATION.
WHY NOT?
THIS IS NOT --
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT THE WAY
IT WORKS.
IF YOU WERE TO INVEST
IN THIS --
[ CHUCKLING ]
OH, IT WORKS THAT WAY FOR ME.
YOUR SALES ARE SQUAT.
WAIT.
TELL HIM HOW IT WORKS.
WE ARE GROWING.
WE'VE DOUBLED OUR SALES,
MONTH OVER MONTH,
OVER THE PAST QUARTER.
FROM PEE-PEE TO PEE-PEE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT? WE DON'T
SPEND MONEY TO GET THAT PEE-PEE.
SO WE DON'T SPEND ANY MONEY,
AND IT STILL KEEPS SELLING.
Cuban: I WANT TO KNOW
THE AVERAGE ORDER.
GIVE ME YOUR METRICS, THEN.
OKAY, SO OUR AVERAGE ORDER
IS $80.
OKAY.
THE CONVERSION FROM
ONE COLLECTION TO THE NEXT --
THE REPEAT PURCHASE
PERCENTAGE -- IS 14%.
THERE -- THAT'S A METRIC
THAT'S SCARY.
THAT'S --
IT'S ACTUALLY HIGH, MARK.
NOT FOR WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
WHEN YOU'RE SMALL.
IN A START-UP COMPANY WHERE YOU
HAVE UNIQUE ATTACHMENT TO PEOPLE
BECAUSE YOU'RE NEW,
THEY FOUND YOU,
NOW'S THE TIME WHEN EVERYBODY
SHOULD BE MOST EXCITED
AND MOST SHARING
AND REORDERING THE MOST.
SO, AGAIN, THE REPEAT-PURCHASE
PERCENTAGE
FROM ONE COLLECTION
TO ANOTHER IS 14%.
HOWEVER, I DON'T THINK
THAT YOU SHOULD LOOK AT IT
IN A VACUUM LIKE THAT.
AND SO, I DON'T THINK
THAT WITH TWO COLLECTIONS,
YOU CAN COME
TO THAT CONCLUSION.
Herjavec:
THAT'S A BIG STATEMENT, RIGHT?
WELL, I THINK THAT YOU
SHOULD STOP CORRECTING
US ON WHAT WE THINK.
I MEAN, THIS EARLY,
THERE SHOULD BE SUCH
A PASSIONATE RESPONSE TO YOU,
SUCH A PASSIONATE RESPONSE TO
WHATEVER COLLECTION YOU PUT UP,
PARTICULARLY SINCE
YOU'RE ONLINE, THAT 14% IS LOW.
RIGHT?
WHETHER IT'S VALUATION
OR, YOU KNOW,
HOW YOU SEE THE FUTURE,
I THINK THERE'S A DISCONNECT,
AND SO, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
OKAY. I APPRECIATE IT.
BEAUTIFUL DESIGNS.
I DON'T SEE IT TODAY
AT THAT VALUE.
I'M OUT.
OKAY. APPRECIATE IT.
UM...
O'Leary: I THINK
YOU MADE A BIG MISTAKE.
I THINK YOU MADE
THE ASSUMPTION
THAT JUST 'CAUSE SOMEONE ELSE
OUTSIDE OF SHARK TANK
WOULD PAY YOU A RIDICULOUS
MULTIPLE FOR YOUR BUSINESS --
BEYOND RIDICULOUS --
THAT YOU COULD BRING THAT
IN HERE AND USE IT AS PROOF
THAT YOU'RE WORTH $9 MILLION
OR $10 MILLION.
AN MBA IS NOT A PREREQUISITE
FOR SUCCESS AT ALL.
I HAVE ONE, TOO.
UNDERSTOOD.
WHO CARES?
YOU HAVE TO GO MAKE MONEY
FOR INVESTORS.
THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS.
I PERSONALLY THINK IT'S WORTH
ABOUT 1.5 MILLION BUCKS.
AND IF I WAS GONNA
GIVE YOU $500,000,
I'D NEED A PREMIUM ON IT.
I MEAN, I THINK,
MAYBE...50/50.
NO, I'M SERIOUS.
I'M SERIOUS, TOO.
NO. NOT HAPPENING.
[ CHUCKLES ]
OKAY.
YOU'RE DEAD TO ME.
I'M OUT.
IF I HAD TO TELL YOU SOMETHING
TO LEARN FROM THIS
THAT I DO THINK
IS IMPORTANT,
WE GET A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN HERE THAT SAY,
"I'M FROM SILICON VALLEY,
SO THEREFORE I'VE RAISED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS."
AND THEY'RE SO IN LOVE
WITH RAISING MONEY
THAT THE BRASS TACKS OF ACTUALLY
SELLING SOMETHING GETS LOST.
I'M OUT.
DAYMOND IS
THE ONLY ONE LEFT.
SO, HOW DO YOU THINK
YOUR NEGOTIATION STYLE
HAS WORKED TODAY?
UM...
PROBABLY NOT THAT WELL.
I HAVE NOTHING
AGAINST STRONG WOMEN.
I DON'T CARE
IF YOU WERE A MALE UP HERE
NEGOTIATING
THE SAME EXACT WAY.
"OH, THAT'S NEVER
GONNA HAPPEN. OH."
AND CORRECTING US
ALL THE TIME,
'CAUSE WE JUST WANT TO GET
THE INFORMATION.
I JUST DON'T THINK
IT WAS THE PROPER WAY.
ON ONE SIDE, HONESTLY,
I DON'T KNOW
IF I'VE SEEN BETTER DESIGNS.
THANK YOU.
SO, UM...
DAYMOND,
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
Narrator:
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
DAYMOND IS CATALINA'S
LAST CHANCE
TO MAKE A DEAL
FOR HER LINGERIE COMPANY NAJA.
DAYMOND,
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
YOUR VALUATION AT $10 MILLION --
I-I CAN'T COME CLOSE TO THAT.
LOOK, WHEN YOU SAT DOWN
WITH THE V.C.s IN THE VALLEY,
YOU HAD TO DO
SOME SORT OF PROJECTION.
MM-HMM.
RIGHT?
SO, ONE-YEAR, THREE-YEAR
PROJECTIONS IN SALES,
WHAT DID YOU TELL THEM?
WHAT ARE MY PROJECTIONS
FOR THIS COMPANY?
OR DID THEY NOT CARE?
AT THAT POINT,
THEY DIDN'T CARE.
WOW.
THAT'S AMAZING.
WHAT DO YOU PROJECT YOUR SALES
TO BE IN TWO YEARS?
FOURT-- ABOUT $14 MILLION
IN REVENUE A YEAR.
John: I'M JUST CURIOUS.
AND THEN THE YEAR AFTER?
BUT WHERE DO YOU GET THAT
PROJECTION FROM? WAIT.
I HAVE TO --
I HAVE TO SOBER THIS DOWN.
FROM THE AIR.
I WONDER WHERE PEOPLE COME UP
WITH THESE REALLY HUGE,
WHAT I CONSIDER
SOMEWHAT CRAZY PROJECTIONS.
AND THIS HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH YOUR LINE.
Herjavec: CATALINA,
DO YOU KNOW HOW HARD IT IS
TO GO FROM $140,000
TO $14 MILLION?
EVEN IN SILICON VALLEY,
DO YOU KNOW HOW LONG IT TAKES
TO GET TO THAT LEVEL?
ORACLE DIDN'T DO IT
IN THAT RATE.
MICROSOFT DIDN'T DO IT
AT THAT RATE.
THERE IS ALREADY MONEY IN THERE,
AND I THINK IT'S STUPID MONEY.
AND I'M -- I'M MAD
THAT IT WAS VALUED AT THAT.
BECAUSE I WOULD
HAVE BEEN ALL IN.
SO, WITH THAT, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD LUCK.
I JUST READ THIS NOTE
ON THE PANTIES, AND IT SAID,
"I'M NOT WORTH
$10 MILLION."
[ LAUGHTER ]